what's up everybody it's warning and
last night we got a huge Avengers
endgame spoiler so needless to say
spoiler warning for this video also I'm
still giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero
so this bomb that was dropped last night
basically confirms time-travel and
Avengers endgame but maybe not in the
way that you think last night in an
interview samuel l.jackson who of course
plays Nick Fury and the Avengers and in
the upcoming Captain Marvel film dropped
a huge spoiler and this is what he said
she's pretty much the strongest
character in terms of someone with
powers are able to do things in the
Marvel Universe
so for Carol Danvers to be that person
and for Bri to become that person it's
gonna be a dynamite thing I mean the
Avengers are up against some really
really tough odds right now we saw
throughout infinity warp so now we know
that we need something that's as
powerful as Stannis at some point we'll
find out how powerful she is and all the
things that she's capable of she's one
of the few people in the Marvel Universe
that can time travel so so samuel
l.jackson in an interview just
straight-up said that carol danvers
captain marvel can time travel that is a
huge leak to avengers endgame that just
confirmed time travel I'm just supposed
to take your word today now how is it
possible that Captain Marvel can time
travel
she doesn't have these powers in the
comics but this could be their way of
tying her in to Avengers end game if
you've watched some of the Captain
Marvel trailer breakdowns that I've done
you've heard me mention quantum energy
so you know that I think and it has also
been said that Captain Marvel is
directly connected to the quantum realm
we've seen in multiple trailers and we
actually just got an even better look in
this special look at Captain Marvel that
Marvel Studios gave us a couple of
nights ago we've seen this explosion
that she's involved in now in the comics
it's the psyche magnetron that explodes
and actually gives her her powers it's a
forbidden creep machine and I'm not sure
that they're going to have that in the
movie but if we look at these scenes and
we look at this explosion it sure does
look like quantum and
and it looks like she somehow absorbs it
much like ghosted in ant-man and the
wasp so perhaps in the MCU she gets her
powers from quantum energy and can now
access the quantum realm and it's by
using this quantum energy that she is
able to time travel we obviously know by
now there's been enough said about the
quantum realm to know that time travel
is possible through it and remember what
Hank Pym said about it he said it's a
reality where all concepts of time and
space become irrelevant as you shrink
for all eternity so in the quantum realm
time and space are irrelevant but what
if you could harness quantum energy and
somehow work your way through the
quantum realm if you could do that you
could probably work your way through
time so perhaps captain marvel is
actually in a different time when Nick
Fury pages her that would actually
explain the weird pager that he has a
lot of us thought that she was deep into
space somewhere and this is some sort of
cosmic pager but what if it's actually a
pager designed to contact her in a
different point in time so Nick Fury
pages her at the end of Avengers
infinity war and then in avengers
endgame she goes to the current time
that he's supposed to be in but when she
comes through the quantum realm to get
to the current time that Nick Fury is in
she finds ant-man she brings him to the
current time which is the current time
that he is actually supposed to be in
and then he introduces her to the
Avengers so the combination of Captain
Marvel's knowledge of time travel and
the quantum realm combined with ant
man's technology leads all of the
Avengers into the quantum realm to
travel back in time this could be what
happens because why would they give
Captain Marvel time-traveling abilities
it's so she can help the Avengers travel
through time in Avengers endgame but let
me know your thoughts on this huge bomb
that samuel l.jackson dropped on us last
night in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]